what is going on everybody welcome to
the 21st financial plotting tutorial
with matplotlib and python where we left
off we made the addition of the relative
strength index to the top of our chart
few things I would like to change about
it but I think the best thing for us to
do is to go ahead and add or at least
start adding the MACD indicator and then
we'll change up the colors with RSI and
the MACD altogether at the same time
probably changes some of these colors
too and just make the chart just
holistically work with itself so we'll
get to the changing of the colors later
in this video and probably the next
probably that leaves one or two videos
we'll be going over the addition of MACD
so what is MACD if you don't know
mackney MACD stands for moving average
Convergence divergence what does that
mean basically the idea of the MACD is
it's kind of like two things and rolled
into one right it it's like a trend
following and also a momentum indicator
you know an RSI is obviously also a bit
of a momentum indicator but it's more of
like a momentum oscillator right but the
MACD is as well so anyway the idea of
the MACD is basically to do trends and
momentum in the way that it works is
well one it has it's got three different
lines to it you've got the actual like
MACD line which is the usually you can
change up the numbers but it's usually
like the twelve day exponential moving
average or rather twelve period
exponential moving average - the 26
period exponential moving average then
you've got the signal line which is the
nine day exponential moving average of
the MACD line which is the one I just
explained and then finally of the MACD
histogram which is the MACD line - that
signal line so kind of confusing but
maybe what I'll do is I'll comment it in
just in case you're not familiar with it
and if you're familiar with it then you
know whatever so so that's what we're
going to be doing
and so the only thing that is left for
question is the exponential moving
average what the heck is that well the
difference between a like a simple
moving average everything carries the
same weight right an exponential moving
average places more emphasis or more
value on more recent data right so the
the newer data means more to the moving
average than the older data and this
kind of helps it react quicker so anyway
that's the difference of that so to do
this we kind of need two things right we
need first of all a function for an
exponential moving average and then we
also need you know the entire MACD
function so as you might guess this is
gonna be a little bit probably like I
said this video at least one other video
and maybe this video in two videos to
get through all of this because then we
actually got to plot it and everything
oh it's gonna be huge so anyway so let's
go ahead and scroll up this is kind of
where we've been storing all of our
functions right so this is where we're
going to begin and I think what we'll do
we'll just put it let's just move this
up a little bit and we'll put
exponential moving average underneath
our moving average so we'll say define
and this will be X and then exp moving
average and again this is going to have
values in a window now what we what
we'll do for this is again it needs to
wait the the closer or more recent data
more and luckily for us numpy has
exponential kind of like built into it
so we can kind of use it so anyway
weights equals NP exp and then we want
to use MPL in space in space negative
one comma zero comma and then the window
now the next thing we want to do is say
weights by weight so just in case you
don't know like dividing equal kind of
works
same as like if you were to do plus
equals right or minus equals you know so
divided by divided equals now the next
thing we want to do is we'll just say a
equals MP dot convolve and what do we
want to do values weights mode equals
full and then the array for this
everything to the length of values so
like all of the data basically yes then
what we want to go ahead and do is say a
window it was the average of window and
then we return average so that's our
exponential moving average function so
now we can actually use it within our
MACD function and I think you know most
of my videos I've been running kind of
long so I think I'll have the video here
and then in the next video we'll create
the function for computing the MACD then
we'll actually I don't know make some
space for Magdi and then we'll actually
plot Magdi so that sounds interesting to
you guys then you should continue on
with the next video as always thank you
for watching thank you for your support
your subscriptions and until next time